it all sounds like a wonderful  commitment to American values and  American history but it's nothing of the  kind in fact the whole thing could be in  breach of a federal law because the  United States flag code establishes  important rules for the use and display  of the Stars and Stripes the flag of the  United States under standards of respect  and etiquette it's made clear that the  flag of the United States should never  be used for any advertising purpose  whatsoever yet that's precisely what  Sarah Palin is doing she's using the  flag of the United States for her own  financial purposes she drapes herself in  the Stars and Stripes and makes millions  of dollars in the process this has got  nothing to do with the presidency and  everything to do with filling her  pockets MSNBC  the place for politics